die große Frage die man sich stellen
muss als Bürger ist sind die so Dorf
oder steckt da ein Plan dahinter meine
meine Meinung ist man kann so doof gar
nicht sein da muss ein Plan dahinter
sein aber für mich sieht es fast
wirklich ich wiederhole mich es sieht
für mich aus wieder später die späte
Erfüllung des morgendau-plans man möchte
nicht und zwar habe ich eine eigene
Theorie entwickelt man hat uns ja immer
dafür kritisiert dass wir zu viel waren
nach außen verkauft haben wie wir
hereingekauft haben und durch diesen
[Musik]
bilanzüberschuss sind wir
schlecht angeschrieben vor allen Dingen
im anno-sächsischen Bereich wir haben
wir sparen zu viel und wir verkaufen zu
viel Ware nach draußen und das haben die
uns vorgebetet wir sollen es endlich
lassen 20 Jahre immer der deutsche kann
eben nicht anders unsere waren waren
ebenso beliebt die Menschen lieben
unsere Autos unsere kühlschranke etc und
wir sparen halt das ist das liegt halt
am deutschen weil wer hat wer spart in
der Zeit der hat in der Not
deswegen werden wir jetzt bestraft unter
dem Motto wer nicht hören will muss
fühlen und
der Terroranschlag auf die Gaspipeline
ist eindeutig eine Kriegserklärung an
die deutsche Industrie an den deutschen
Bürger an uns nur das will man nicht
wahrhaben wir leiden unter kollektiven
Stockholm-Syndrom der Stockholm Syndrom
war die sind entführt worden und haben
sich dann mit ihren Entführern
angefreundet damit einfach die Zeit in
der Gefangenschaft nicht so schrecklich
ist und so kommt mir das vor bei uns
weil wir müssen endlich an deutsche
Interessen denken wir müssen an unsere
Bürger denken wir müssen dann wir müssen
uns emanzipieren und das gelingt eben
offensichtlich nicht und jetzt geht es
ein Bach runter und wenn wenn er wenn
die Not groß ist aber wer den Schaden
hat braucht für den Spott nicht zu
sorgen die ganze Welt lacht über
Deutschland also ganz konkret sie sagen
wir können nicht ohne russisches Gas
nein wir können wenn wir Atomwaffen
müssen wir kein russisches Gast aber die
Energiewende ist ja deswegen gescheitert
weil man den Russen gesagt dass wir
kaufen euch nichts mehr ab bevor man
sich aber dass man eine Alternative
hätte die Alternative kann doch nicht
sein dass wir jetzt Flüssiggas über den
See über übers Meer von den Amerikanern
holt was ist denn das für ein Fußabdruck
das ist ja das sind ja riesige
dieseltanker wir müssen die LNG
Terminals neu bauen das ist doch auch
nicht Umwelt besser bei Umwelt besser
wäre die Pipeline gewesen und und das
Methangas was jetzt rausgeht das ist
anscheinend auch egal wo hat man uns
gesagt das wäre der Super-GAU viel
schlimmer als das was die die eine eine
Entscheidung will ist dass das Methangas
jetzt frei wird und in die Luft geht zu
1000 und abertausenden Kubikmetern das
wäre ihre Forderung ganz konkret
zusammengefasst an die deutsche Politik
wie man jetzt mit Putin und Russland
umgehen muss nein man muss sich vor
erste zuerst mal einen Washington wenn
das ist unser großer Bruder die die
Musik spielt den Washington das sind die
Bosse mit denen müssen wir reden vor da
müssen wir sagen Leute geraden wir
lieben euch wir sind alle Amerika
freundlich wir lieben die Amerikaner
aber hier macht ihr einen großen Fehler
ihr treibt die Russen in die Arme der
Chinesen das ist nicht gut weil die
Russen gehören eigentlich zu Europa und
die haben sich auch immer Europa
zugehörig gefühlt dieses russen-bashing
ist immer falsch gewesen man ist mit den
Russen auch nicht richtig umgegangen und
jetzt haben wir den Salat man hat die
Russen nicht an den Verhandlungstisch
gelassen man hat sie am Katzentisch
sitzen lassen das macht man nicht mit
einem Tausendjährigen Reich wir Fragen
hier einmal Herr Knabe Herr Knabe
empfinden sie das auch so dass wir
erstmal mit Amerika reden müssen und die
Russen nicht am Katzentisch sitzen
lassen dürfen nein also das
sehe ich die Fürstin Schätze und ihr
gerade zugestimmt habe möchte ich da
doch mal an herkes widersprechen
was ich da abgespielt hat in den letzten
Monaten ist aus meiner Sicht eindeutig
von einer Seite zu verantworten nämlich
von Russland und von einem Mann
insbesondere Herrn Putin der in der
Ukraine Einmarsch und da seine Bomben
geworfen hat auf Zivilisten und wirklich
ein Massenmörder ist und mit so einem
Mann zu sprechen
das ist faktisch nicht mehr möglich die
hat sich selbst ins Abseits manövriert
und ich wundere mich oft über die
Naivität in Deutschland wenn man also
denkt das wäre so ein ganz normaler
Politiker mit dem man irgendwie
verhandeln könnte und Kompromisse
schließen könnte der vielleicht in der
Partei irgendwie aufgestiegen ist dann
bei Wahlen sich durchgesetzt hat nein
das ist ein knallharter KGB-Mann der hat
das von der Pike auf gelernt er wollte
schon in der neunten Klasse zum KGB in
leningen
Vergangenheit
beschäftigt was ist da so noch an
Unterlagen gibt über seine Zeit beim KGB
und da merkt man
wie in das geprägt hat Lügen täuschen
Irre führen langen Atem haben um
operative Kombination durchzuführen wie
die das genannt haben um einen Menschen
dazu zu bringen das zu machen was man
selber möchte und der Mensch eigentlich
nicht will